get felix
colin ken from australia i'm here baby
what you need
oh finally you're back we can record tlc
again
i got withdrawals right to watch more
tlc with you oh my god
i had to think of original video ideas
while you were gone to fill the gap
it's not like i did that anyway i don't
know why i said that
anyway kim's back let's go tlc
have you seen this one man heats up food
in his jacuzzi
of course i've never seen this one ever
before i feel like i've seen this and in
the back of my mind
i'm like have i made a video on this oh
god am i just recycling content
dude i get i get comments like that i'll
make a video and people like
have you done this already and i'm like
just freaking search it on my channel
see if you can find it jesus
no of course i haven't done it yet maybe
[Laughter]
i know this is like a classic tlc ryan
heats up food in this jacuzzi
good old cheapskates i'm excited that's
what
an online dating service todd was
not paying for it and i was paying for
it and that's where you should have
ended it no you know what i respect that
guys don't have to pay that's right yeah
yeah it's 20 21 all right guys don't
always have to pay
yeah she was like oh my god this is the
first time like a guy's ever made me pay
for the food this is so hot
what a bold move he's so cool he made me
pay
he's so confident so confident little
did she know
see they couldn't even afford shoes at
the wedding
[Laughter]
it's the beach wedding you know when you
go out to the beach and you have to wear
white
and i don't know get tan which they
didn't do
red flags you're a red flag all right
rude he doesn't have to pay whatever he
does i'm on his side
okay i realized pretty quickly that he
was different from anyone else i had
dated before
one christmas whoa what is happening
here what gave it away like his freaking
dexter house where he's gonna murder you
you went through this sound after a day
we're like you know what
gotta dent this thing i think uh
how are you alive what is all this what
is this
freaking ketchup in this mustard under
plastic over here what is all that oh
man his car is parked on top of a tarp
too why is he gonna get like his
wheels are gonna get the ground dirty
the wheels can't get dirty can i'll be
insane
todd bought me doritos and chocolate
chips for christmas
well that's a nice thoughtful gift all
right
i'm on his site what what what do you
expect jewelry
cliche doritos
hell yeah nothing says lovely like
doritos
anyway this is sponsored by on our first
date this is what we had together
because that's all we could afford and
oh it brings back memories so sweet what
kind of chocolates
huh maybe they're really nice ones
important
doubt it it's probably like true i don't
know supermarket
what's your opinion on american
chocolates
i have no opinion obviously they're
great
well i was talking to a to it to a uh a
british man another youtuber and
he's all about chocolates he loves
british chocolates
yeah he's like he asked me he's like so
what do you think about american
chocolates
like i guess they're good and he's like
no they're terrible they're freaking
sour they're gross they even make it
sour because
back in the day the milk would go bad
inside the chocolate when they got to
america and all this other stuff
yeah that's true i've heard of my face
some reese's pieces you know
well i spoke to some british friends too
and they're like it tastes like vomit
a lot of british people think american
chocolate tastes like vomit and there's
actually a scientific reason why because
that compound that american factories
use
it's the same that you can detect in uh
vomit
same chemical so people aren't wrong for
thinking it is it is actually
vomit vomit chocolate the more you know
here at
pewdiepie toc there you go i just
learned so much
freaking chad moves here dude just gave
her some vomit for christmas and she
loved it
it does taste like [ __ ] i'm not gonna
lie even swedish chocolate is the batter
but sweetheart chocolate what kind of
chocolate the sweet sweets
[Music]
[ __ ] commercials burning to my brain
oh my god i've only sweet song like
that was like the cool [ __ ] and you know
dance around the big ball sack for
fertility during the summer
that was terrible ken you got a quack
quack
sorry i didn't mean to offend you don't
even try it
okay if you're gonna do it half-ass like
that
what's this video about again crazy
people can
unlike us right right i think my habits
did get to her after a while
she would sometimes joke and say that
she was on the crazy train
you know pun intended since i drive
trains she got off a crazy train
oh god he has it everywhere yeah plastic
on the floor
oh my god seriously your tinder date
brings you back to your home this is his
house what do you do
i'm running the trains i'm going
straight down the track and
uh i can do whatever i want well right
now
uh fridge times very specific fridge
times 8 37
is that when he like turns the fridge on
you know you got an optimum the
temperature
440 what is that what is in his fridge
what is this oh god
what is in the fridge no the water
always up in the freezer
every tlc video obligatory weird [ __ ] in
the freezer
uh in ziploc bags i don't have to put
them in a washing machine
it actually it's his clothes this is
cool he keeps his pants pots and pans
what what
what kind of life hack is this it kills
the bacteria by having them in here that
way i save on
uh laundry detergent i save on time i
don't have to use electricity to run my
washing machine
damn what okay more fun facts with the
felix
they did a test on jeans and they
discovered that
people that have not washed their jeans
in a year
almost has as much bacteria as someone
that hasn't washed it and
washed it in a week well you're not even
like actual blue jeans like real blue
jeans you're not supposed to watch
anyway
oh yeah you just don't wash them i don't
know why it's just how
just the way it is he puts his stuff in
the in
his freezer and it kills the bacteria
maybe i've just seen too many movies but
in their like movies where they like go
to antarctica and like dig something up
and the bacteria murders everyone
because it's been dormant there the
whole time
right that's right what the hell you
just
ruined the thing for me now the movie oh
my god
it makes nonsense they get them in the
end it's fine yeah
[Laughter]
why don't i put them in the oven then
prior to japan so it got hot
nice and hot yeah we've got roads with
my pants i think it was such a crazy
movie
remember the first time you watched the
thing how old were you uh
i actually didn't see it until like
recently oh
dude i watched it when i was like a
teenager and like the first like
it's gross like the the way they do it
all ah it looks
freaking creepy fun fact with felix they
actually used gum
for a lot of their stringing effects on
the who do you watch movies with it like
tells you all this stuff
i've watched too many youtube videos ken
that's it
you watch the movie then go watch
youtube videos about it i don't know
how i know these pointless things can
but i have a need to share them okay
sorry well maybe that's what made it so
scary they used actual bubble gum and
like chewed bubble gums like the
grossest thing on the planet
freaked me out man yeah that was from
yeah yeah
the freaking head skittering around oh
it's a legitimately great film
i like it but anyway this guy's crazy
yeah
dude the thing i just thought about this
i'm sorry the thing is the original
concept for among us
oh yeah i forgot about that there you go
kids now you have something to
understand what we were talking about
ah no among us anybody that anybody that
still plays among us
is this dead is over with dude it's
still like the top
nintendo store what yeah
well i mean nothing else has come out in
like two years so i guess that makes
sense
okay i forgot before i forget ken you
still got your mustache
hell yeah still got my mustache you
mustache hater british people are
disgusting ken
okay listen to this thirty percent of
those
asked confess they wash their bed sheets
once a year or less
the thing is growing in everyone's bed
basically
they wash their bed sheets once a year
or less
once a year how much sweat and
skin you can make a whole other person
out of that amount of skin that's in a
bed
i'm pretty fat and i sweat at night
right and then
i mean how do i say this are all these
people like single
because you know sometimes you just
gotta wash your bed sheets don't wash
your bed sheets right now
do it right now pause the video we'll
wait we'll wait
take three hours please wash your bed
sheets you freaking disgusting people
dude it gets worse it gets worse hold up
i got a fun fact for you that goes along
with this
so apparently over time your mattress
gets heavier
because it absorbs all your sweat and
your dead skin
so like you know you get your mattress
like oh it's not that heavy and then
like 10 years later like jesus christ i
can't move this thing because it's
filled up like
oh dude that woman that ate the mattress
have you seen her on tlc
[Laughter]
oh my god she's eating people
she's literally eating her family she's
as bad as the lady that actually eats
her dead boyfriend oh my god
have you seen that one the one where she
eats the ashes of her dead husband
oh i have yet to see that lovely clip
all right
you should check it out and i'll pretend
like i've never seen it what did that
say that safety they only changed their
underwear like
i don't remember but it's like not
enough change your underwear
put it in your freezer so it kills at
least put it in the freezer i'm
this guy he's done it right i'm on his
side the whole time look at that
like brand new yeah
it's like it's like i just bought them
yeah but you're not supposed to wash
them anyway according to ken so
joke's on you idiot by tightly packing
his fridge with clothes
cookware and canned goods todd cuts his
energy use
by nearly 10 but you don't have to keep
cans in the fridge that's the whole
point right am i missing something here
well they got enough salt in them that
where you can just keep it forever
anyway right
yeah what's the point how long
look at all these condiments he has in
his freaking drawer right here this
dude's not saving any money look at
those condiments
yeah too many can respect this
the refrigerator doesn't cycle on as
much and it doesn't produce or
uh consume as much electricity close the
door
close the door you're killing the planet
close the door he's
wasting those money closer
i don't care that some people might
think that some of my habits are over
the top now
i got clothes in my refrigerator for
god's sake i mean it's that's pretty
cheap
that's not the weirdest part the
weirdest part is whatever the hell you
got going on with all this plus
what what is that what is
[Laughter]
without him laughing or the thing i
don't know
i care about comfort he cares about
saving money
our hair comes oh yeah
let's go
there's no need for me to use the
washing machine because it just cost too
much money
i could just reuse the water right here
there's a lot of wear and tear on your
clothes in the washing machine
i'm able to wash my clothes in here my
clothes my clothes last for years
do you think he has guests over and they
go in their jacuzzi together
you saw this dude's house plastic
everywhere
of course this dude has tons of guests
over that's why he
so they don't track dirt into his house
yeah oh man
hop in come on man what is what is great
feeling's good
come on man yeah come on man it's fine
oh sorry i didn't bring any
swim to suit no don't worry it's fine
i'm in my short stick
come on it looks clean it's so good it's
all good
coming in the water first of all does
this make sense doesn't jacuzzi
take a lot of energy in itself yeah
wouldn't it be cheaper to not have a
jacuzzi and then just wash your clothes
hot tubs are considered personal
property and do not affect the resale
value of a home
all right never mind
they don't affect the resale value what
a soup in my
plastic container and uh but you'd be
surprised at how quickly it heats up
i think people probably use their
microwave every day
to 40 or almost 40 a month
it's almost ready what kind of
microwaves do what
forty dollars that's soup that soup is
cold as hell dude
i guarantee it how much soup you think
he's dumped in this jacuzzi
he must have spilled so much soup yeah
the freaking numbers they run on the
show
blow my mind it's like you know hey i
don't flush my toilet ever and i've
saved
800 a month yeah right sure
okay great i just spit in the toilet
free water don't have to flush
i'm not idiots add any value to the
house oh he's blowing on it
he's blowing on it like it's so hot
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
oh sure buddy it's just boiling water
and that could
be happening at all the time like what
oh dude i decided to use it for
multi-purposes
for everything that i can think of
he's like there's jacuzzi with such a
bad investment so i gotta make the most
out of it
yeah washes all this stuff and cooks his
soup and then as he will hop in there
and wash his ass on it yeah
look at that look at that soapy mess
what is that i ain't going in there
so mildly wait little hairs on it
it costs about 15 a month to take a 10
minute shower every day
and that adds up by using my shot i
would say i'm saving about 30 to 40
a month that way i don't have to use my
appliances i could turn off the hot
water heater
this hot tub i mean this thing is a
money saver i mean this is like a cash
he's he's just trying to justify buying
this hot dog
it saves me money it's great
i can eat my soup soup was so hot it
could have burned my mouth so let me hop
in the hot tub oh wow
oh it's i'm just super human i'm built
different
i don't know why hot tub resellers
aren't just uh selling hot tubs with
soup heaters
you're right you're right you know what
if you buy these hug that you don't have
to use a microwave anymore it's great
i think it's a stroke of genius myself
sure
they always think like they they're so
smart that's a that's a common theme
with cheapskates where they just
think they're they beat themselves so
much smarter than the average person all
right
like 80 a month by jumping in the
jacuzzi and doing everything in the
jacuzzi
yeah the medical bills whenever you get
sepsis or something or whatever it is
right
no no they don't worry about it todd's
free time is spent
preserving the value of things that he
has
okay i'm planning on selling this car
and uh i want to try to get the best
deal i can
this car is 10 years old and you would
not know that by looking at it
i mean hey it's an out all right
well that's not how car sales work there
fella you actually got to tell them the
year the car and they run the vin number
and all that information comes back and
your hubcaps busted
yeah i knew all that too yeah yeah
and the mileage yeah exactly it's like
comes in like mileage and like how old
the car is doesn't matter like what
condition it's in
i mean it does but you know at the same
time that's
not the major anyway yeah i mean that
car looks like it's in good shape i'm
not gonna lie
he could probably get a lot of that car
if i were to sell my car
i think i could probably get 3 000 for
fair condition and
6 000 for good condition easily jesus
6 000 for a good so twice the value
because it's in good condition he's
doubled the value because
wow
[Music]
let's get it wrapped up here's what
normal people do they clean the car
before they sell it
yeah yeah you go pay a guy like 20. you
can you can do that details the whole
thing
you don't have to you don't have to live
like things
the uh the dashboard and on the steering
wheel but i've got those seats i've got
it on the floor mats
most cars get a lot of that weather has
this guy heard of a vacuum
or wipes no he just spends all his money
buying plastic and tape
some news magazines on the on the
steering wheel
the sun just bleaches a lot of the
plastic but i don't get that in my car
my car is just
perfect i mean it's as good as the day i
bought it uh-huh
yeah good thing you've been able to
enjoy it maybe this is how he enjoys it
though
to be fair i've gone on my way to
preserve this car as much as i can so
the next owner can enjoy it
yeah exactly but you know when that you
sell your car the first thing they say
is like oh that
it's bleached inside by the sun i mean
this is not gonna sell it i don't hear
that all the time
we're gonna have to knock off at least
6000 on the price of this
yeah those are like a danger like what
every time the cops being called on them
there's this dude what is with the
clothes everybody's trying his freaking
clothes in his back seat bro just
driving the jacuzzi what are you doing
put it in the you know the freezer it'll
it'll turn into ice you just knock it
off
[Laughter]
i was drawing some clothes in the dryer
and i thought why am i spending money
well i can just you know you don't
people hang their colors you're not
you're not slick there yeah what do you
mean you just go hang it outside
you don't have to drive your car around
wasting gas because you care so much
about money
oh my god how many how many items can
you fit in a car
anyway like there was like three
garments in there
what's that this guy's just having a
laugh dude this can't be serious this is
dumb this makes no sense he can't be
serious
why am i spending money well i can just
you know put him in the back of my car
and dry them in there
i did it a couple times and it worked
like a champ how's that cheaper
you're heating up three shirts it's not
it's not
what are you all about oh man i think
the clothesline in the car is ridiculous
ty can't afford to dry his clothes in
the damn dryer oh i swore
the average man oh you swore demonetized
it only takes about two or three hours
for my clothes to uh dry in the backseat
or you can just hang them overnight
anywhere and they'll be dry
you even gotta hang them you can just
take one of like a chair from his house
and like just throw a shirt off the back
of it and put it outside
that works for me i don't know what the
problem
each of my stops each what's that what
happened to your alloy there buddy huh
yes talk about that earlier it was like
busted like all good condition you know
yeah
yeah we didn't see that huh discount
near expired food toward the end of the
day oh great
well so todd has this thing where he
goes to the store
and he peruses the fish and meats
and looks at the dates well usually old
meat
is is uh good right yeah i mean
they discount it because not because
it's bad but because
it needs to be cooked like within the
next couple days right
and i'm sure he does that he does not
keep them in this jacuzzi or something
like that yeah
it gets discolored a little bit too when
it's discolored even if it's still good
people don't want to buy it because
they're like ah
gross no i get that but this is normally
for people that want to save money
uh because they can't afford it this guy
can afford it you think he's gonna
haggle you think he's gonna be like hey
bro this is uh going out you're gonna
throw it away you know how about uh
it's for free give me a sweet deal free
how about you pay me so he'll buy all
the
the fish that's on clearance that
they're about to throw out
this guy is like defensive
when i get something cheap when i find a
good deal
i feel really good it uh makes my day
any uh good deals on seafood today i do
what you're looking for
anything that's uh gonna be past its
expiration date
do you have anything that's old anything
expired
[Music]
you know if the packages are broken open
i'll take a look
there you go there's a deal see that one
broken yeah
you're gonna have it for half price what
about this one this one's the dancer
this one's a little brown he's looking
at the worst ones he could possibly
at this one this one's moldy huh so you
know
uh at your establishment when you sell
food you sell anything that's like out
of date and expired and the guy's like
no i want to get sick as quick as
possible yeah exactly
we have some meat we totally forgot
about it it's been sitting there for
the past decade you can get that what do
you give me on that one
i see a lot that one looks like it's
been opened up that's cool
but is this 99 something
99 cents i'll take that for 99. what is
this 99 something
yeah back in the 1950s
you want 99 cents 99 cents go for it
he was like i don't give a [ __ ] okay
he's like dudes go away man
yeah exactly yeah what
i estimate that i probably save about 75
a month
on expired groceries that most people
don't want
and uh i can save me up to about 900 a
year when i'm satisfied congratulations
yeah exactly you did it huge amazing you
did it
you're the man when i'm satisfied
knowing that it's the lowest price i can
get
then i buy it all throw it in my freezer
and
yeah i'm living like a king samples
living like a king customers but go
ahead
go ahead and i even got a free uh
little chocolate that's huge do you
think he's over there just like
oh god you want to come over and see my
jacuzzi bro
the water's great trust me bro he he's
the kind of guy that goes to random
receptions just to grab the candy and be
like
i save so much money on canada it's
incredible oh my god it's so free it's
oh it's great
oh oh man what a guy
what a guy i'm not on his side i tried i
really tried but i came
no not at all when i used to wash her my
peanut bucket and drink instead of
getting me water
shakes me approximately
oh man i bet he doesn't even replace the
hot tub water of course he doesn't
care he's not it's just like freaking
that's why he's got to put all his
clothes to kill him in the in the
freezer because he washes them in the
bacteria water where they're from
god i feel sick if he feels physically
ill as well
smash like on this video oh my god yeah
yeah yeah
one more subscriber he gets another
subscriber oh that's true
also check out ken we got another toc
video up on his channel
thanks for watching wash your clothes
wash your sheets will be washed catching
you know don't give don't give your wife
doritos and chocolate for christmas you
won't have a wife anymore no that's cool
you can do that